[Music]
to be with you guys i just binged all
eight episodes so it's crazy kind of
being with the paper girls themselves
right now and everybody that is fina
strazza aka kj riley lee melet aka aaron
and cameron jones aka tiffany paper
girls out now prime video spoilers in
this interview so make sure you watch
the full season first before you watch
this interview how you guys doing today
we're doing well
good um so my first question is for fina
were you always going to play kj or did
you ever audition for anyone else as
well
uh i actually auditioned for mac as well
i went through my entire audition
process and i screen tested for kj and
for mac so i oh
funny you asked that
that is
very interesting and that's that's going
to get a lot of people talking about
that that's so cool um yeah and look i'm
happy under playing kj you absolutely
bring that character life and do what i
mean i definitely think they made the
right decision all around
hell yeah now uh riley do you find a lot
of yourself in the character of aaron or
do you find a lot of differences
um i think at first what really drew me
to playing aaron was that i feel like we
differentiate in a lot of ways but as i
got to know her more i really started to
find bits of myself and that sense of
having duty and honor is what my dad
always taught me and um yeah i just
learned to love that she really tries to
take care of the people that she loves
and i'm excited for people to see her
yeah and i love what you bring to erin
and that she's honorable like you're
saying and a leader really awesome and
cameron are you excited about being in
this big
franchise series based off this big
comic that you're gonna now eventually
have these tiffany funko pops up here
action figures going to conventions is
that like insane for you right now yeah
i'm very excited for that like i'm ready
for them to start making tips
walkie-talkies to toys like i
think it would be so cool to have a chip
funko pop i'd buy one immediately like
i would post it all over i
and we're going to comic con like i
don't that i'm so excited for that
and i can't wait
yeah no that's great to see you're
excited about that and it's definitely
coming it's so deserving so really cool
and then
uh fina the moment a lot of people talk
about is in the finale
mac puts her hand on kj's hand in the
barn
how what was kj just like that exactly
is it what was kj feeling in that moment
would you say what are you feeling in
this moment right now
yeah thanks
[Laughter]
i kj is feeling a lot of things i mean
she
she's always known that there's been
something that doesn't quite fit in
about her and she's known that there's
been something about her that she hasn't
discovered yet and so when she does
discover that she is gay in the future
she or
in in the future she discovers she's gay
she's always gay
when she discovers that she has to come
to terms with it because she's grown up
in the 80s and
is
it has been taught that that is not okay
and so
in that moment
she
is definitely
feeling a lot of things she
has this relationship with mac where
they are often butting heads and in this
moment where mac has softened she
doesn't know how to deal with it and
we'll see
what happens with that if we're able to
explore it more possibly in the second
season
yeah definitely everyone fingers crossed
and that's yeah kj and mac we're
exciting to see that kind of
relationship evolve it's gonna be
interesting and
riley from people following you on
instagram you could see that you are a
absolute legend in the field of martial
arts can you push
for aaron to be able to use some martial
arts if we have this possible season two
you know i feel yeah i feel like in this
first season it would it wouldn't make a
lot of sense if she knew
martial arts but yeah i was talking to
our writers about that like if we wanted
to do another season it would be cool to
kind of venture off into
using martial arts because i one day
want to do my own stunts and
even coordinate them and that would be a
lot of fun oh that's exciting to hear
yeah and it'd be cool to see you bring
your martial arts skills into stunt as
well um
cameron i'm gonna ask you a hard
question what do you think is the
biggest change in tiffany from the start
of season one to the end like her
journey what do you what would you say
wow this is hard you were right this is
a hard question
i'd say
tiff was very much a loner at the
beginning of season one she didn't have
a lot of friends so she did turn towards
turn towards technology for her comfort
and leaning in towards school and
knowledge and using that to replace her
friends and by the end i feel like she
cares about these girls very very much
and she's let people in
and um
she was the the cliffhanger
made her very very very sad because
she accepted them she cares about them
she finally felt comfortable with the
group of girls
like
i'd say the biggest change is that she
accepted that it's okay to let people in
i love that answer and yeah i could
totally see that too and you did a great
job of showing that arc going through
the season um
now the same question for all of you
we'll start with finna you're gonna lead
off but what was your favorite
moment of season one
favorite moment like
watching it or to film
either one
your call
well i'd say just watching overall i
love the pilot i think it's such a fun
ride and it's so intense
every time i watch it i just love it
even more and then to film
well
one of my favorite moments to film was
also in the pilot the scenes in the car
where where
riley's dying
yeah that was her favorite part was
that
because we we had a stunt driver who was
in a little baby car that was attached
to the side that had full control over
the station wagon and so cameron was
really sitting in that front seat and so
we were able to shoot out the front
windshield there was no trailer pulling
the car so um they really sent us down a
road two and a half miles swiveled and
swerved the car like crazy so all the
bumping that you may see is real we
really screeched to a stop that was very
intense and yeah
donut caught us
it was so fun so dangerous yeah so funny
so it was not dangerous because we were
actually really really safe like the
stunt coordinator and everybody was
great
um i think i think my favorite part was
scenes yeah like the car scene where the
stakes were just really really high i
loved doing the forest
battle scene that was a lot of fun
um
yeah all the all the dirt most of the
dirt that you see flying around is made
of chocolate cake and cookies and cereal
it smells really good it smells really
good the camera what was yours
i think my favorite ones to film were
the car scenes i really liked the second
one in
episode three
i think it's three i think it's true
that one was really fun because i
remember it was really high impact and
she was
oh my gosh
and she was yelling at me
i kept i kept like laughing
not laughing but i kept trying not to
laugh to the point where like okay
cameron's driving the car i'm here and
then i'm
and she is shaking my arm as i'm
pretending to drive and i'm trying so
hard not to laugh
and that was really really fun and she's
yelling at me
it was so keep your eyes on the road
yeah removing like a turtle
so that was my favorite and the rave
yeah that was my favorite to watch the
rave the party it was it was a party
like aesthetically and visually pleasing
i i love it all and for everyone who's
seen the show i mean every scene was
amazing to watch and thank you guys
again for joining me watch fina cameron
and riley kill it it's on prime video
now and paper girls i'll talk to you
guys in the future one day thank you
thank you for having us have a great day